if you wanna be my lover you gotta get
with Mike welcome back to grandma with
me joshing tonight and today we're
joined by the smoothest man in music
Michael Buble you're very sweet for
saying that today we're gonna play a
game called be more be play because I
want to be more be play in my everyday
life are you ready I'm so ready it's so
ready
okay so firstly I've always imagined
that you smile well nice
what's your fragrance five are you no
one in my life has ever asked me it's
weird you know it sounds like I'm
talking about food but I really think
something is fresh
I always liked something fresh if you
gonna sell your fragrance on like a
perfume counter in the department store
how would you go about it I feel like
you should do the French accent for it
oh of course I would use a very accent
it's very romantic
yeah and very sexy can you imagine how
uncomfortable that would be I know that
even to try I don't want to sell I don't
want to sell something for me also you
are kind of like the ultimate Jen I
think I could be a bit more gentlemanly
what your top tips are being the
ultimate gentleman I wish I was that guy
I really do I mean I try to be more like
that guy I could pretend but you know I
think there are certain things that will
never go out of style
I think kindness compassion empathy
humor self deprecation looks muscles
height hair those are all just
unimportant things that in time will go
it's how you make other people feel you
know yeah that's why I tell myself every
day before I go to the gym and then
don't go because now I'm a big karaoke
fan if what's your catchy song I like
stuff that gets the whole place like
yeah like pumping YMCA or like yeah
strong friends in low places because
when I do it I pretend I'm like the sick
remember this last yeah what's your
favorite well cuz I can't sing so I'm
always like who can want to be spice up
you lie the one if I had to choose I
wouldn't do the one that probably most
of the people know I mean not that
people don't know that
yeah I really really really really sick
I said ah if you wanna be my lover you
gotta get with Mike if you thinking like
that oh you know how you feel that's how
I was in the store yeah except I would
do it with a mix of French like it would
be mmm
ma if you want to be mind uh you have to
be with my friends my kind of like
dating game is like on the floor right
now and I feel like I need some tips
from you about how I can raise it what
should I do
honestly yeah no good man yeah you sit
your kind empathetic you're very
handsome
you're charming honestly it's be
yourself just be yourself okay great not
that I have any look at me I mean I took
me a long time to love myself you know
just to love myself enough to be loved
what you tell yourself when you have
nice down days you're an [ __ ]
you need to learn your respect for
yourself now there's too much of my life
where I was like God man you don't it
sounds like such a cliche but if you
don't love you have no one else gonna
love you
words word just love yourself that's
going to the top of my tinder Presler so
what are your Christmas entertaining
tips because surely like going to your
house at Christmas would be like the oh
man is it serious
it's I love I love it yeah actually it's
hard probably for any of you to
understand anybody watching this how how
much it means to me how grateful I am
really I'm not joking but at your house
with your beautiful family at a time
that means so much to you that's so
personal that somehow you got Mickey
bubbles playing in the background to
your casa
that's massive to me man hey you guys
thanks for watching for more videos like
this you can go check it out at
Glamour's youtube channel boom
[Music]